un espeso rocas y lava en el quinto día
de erupción del volcán cumbre vieja en
la isla española de la palma más de 350
casas han quedado sepultadas por la lava
cuyo avance se ha ralentizado pero ya
cubre unas 166 hectáreas pese a la
ralentización de la colada en algunos
puntos alcanza alturas de hasta 12
metros los habitantes de la isla están
en vilo mi hermano
a esas zonas de momento no se ha llevado
a ninguna de sus casas todos tenemos
pero es todo estamos todos estamos al
vídeo todos los días por qué
si se lleva de un hermano aunque va a
haber
pero la tuya
este jueves los reyes de españa junto
con el presidente del gobierno español
pedro sánchez visitaron algunos de los
más de 6.000 evacuados en una muestra de
solidaridad algunos residentes tuvieron
la oportunidad de volver a sus hogares a
recoger sus pertenencias con la ayuda de
los bomberos como muchos en la isla
francisco trabajo en una plantación de
bananos y su medio de vida también está
en riesgo de ser destruido por los
estragos del volcán que arrasa
doscientas de plantaciones agrícolas
no sabemos el tiempo que estaremos en
volver porque van a estar las carreteras
cerradas
y nadie te cambia toda la vida
hay gente peor que se llevó a sus casas
y pasándolo mal también nos afecta del
trabajo ahora mismo estamos esperando
para ver si podemos ir a trabajar o no
nos afecta a todos la vida nos cambió la
vida
si las coladas alcanza la costa
atlántica los científicos advierten de
que la interacción del mar con la lava
podría generar columnas de vapor de agua
con gases ácidos ademas mataría a toda
la vida marina sobre la que recaiga al
magma